so something I quite like thinking about
as well is the single line or the single
phrase that describes how you are
motivated okay what do you mean so um I
hadn't really thought about this before
until a friend who has a he's got an
Amazon affiliate site and his big goal
was to get to number one in terms of
monthly hits and he told me that this
was his big goal he told me that he was
doing hermit mode for like a year to get
there until he was number one and he
showed me this thing that he' made on
Photoshop that was like a leaderboard of
his website which was currently I think
I think it was like number four um and
all these like competitors like Rivals
enemies I think he called them yeah and
he'd set it up like a video game and it
was it was a video game it was a
leaderboard and all the ones below him
he'd struck through and he'd written
killed so it was like a very violent it
was a very violent leaderboard and his
goal was to get to number one and what
he knew is that leader boards motivated
him the idea of killing the competition
motivates him the idea of like being
right at the top having put the work in
it's like his real thing and I tried to
do it with my business I tried to do it
with Coach Fox AI I said to him so how
do I replicate this and he kind of
showed me what kind of leaderboard I
could make he had a look on Google to
see who had monthly traffic similar to
ours etc etc and I looked at this
leaderboard and it did nothing for me I
was not motivated at all to do that
because that's just not my success
that's not my made motivating factor so
it's like finding yours and in a similar
way to um how we came up with your
success system go back through your
biggest achievements and figure out why
it meant so much and why it really meant
so much so
like setting up a bit setting up your
own business might not be because of the
financial stuff it might because of the
freedom stuff um like having kids or um
getting married or like any anything
that you ever think like yes this meant
a lot it might not be because of the
reason that other people think it should
mean a lot there might be something in
it for
you and mine I know because a friend of
a friend who I had a chat with sent me a
personality test I think it was the
insights personality test and it's so
long you answer all these questions and
I I think I had like 24 pages whoa um
but one of the lines in it was is
motivated by the idea of succeed leing
Against All
Odds and when I look back at
stuff the main thing that makes the
difference and stands out in anything is
when someone says to me like there's
hardly any chance of you doing that or
oh this is like only one in a million
people do this or I remember at my
company's thirdd birthday party and our
lawyer came and said oh W done you've
got you've gotten the 10% of businesses
who own who make it past three years and
I was like yeah of course we have but I
quite like I like this idea that there
are really really really Slim odds and
that we're going to we're going to smash
them that's interesting cuz that nothing
for me as you were saying that I was
like so interesting and I speak to so
many people who are like oh you know
someone told me I couldn't do it and
then I thought it I'm going to do
it and I'm like really that's motivating
um I was on a podcast called built to
sell and John waro the host said
something like we've done 300 episodes
and of all these 300 episodes you're the
only one who sold without having to do
an earnout and in my head it was like
300- one and I was like that's me that's
the one and that's like the thing that's
the real thing whereas the leaderboard
yeah nothing but the there's other
things so it's like find yours and then
use that again going forward and kind of
fabricate situations that will mean that
you are motivated because you can think
of it in that way just like my friend
Richard with his leader board and
killing all the competition hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day byebye